I was 14 years old in 1994
when my country, South Africa,
held its historic first
democratic elections.
I can vividly remember my mother
taking me with her to the voting station,
which was near the clinic
where she worked,
and where she would cast her vote
for the very first time
in a general election
at the age of 45 years old.
That's two years older than I am today,
standing in front of you.
By then, my mother was a taxpayer
and a home owner,
and she was a mother of four children.
She was a university graduate
who had a long and storied
career behind her
in South Africa's public health service.
She had raised us and educated us
and imbued in all of us the religious
and cultural traditions of our ancestors.
In other words, she was a fully-fledged
adult woman of 45 years old.
But she had never been allowed
to vote in an election before
because she was also Black.
Take a moment to think
about what that day
and that election must have meant for her
and for the millions
of Black South Africans
who were voting for the very first time.
People who were previously
not even considered legitimate citizens
in the country of their birth.
It took five long years of negotiations
for the multiracial, multiparty Convention
for a Democratic South Africa,
and later for the first
democratic parliament,
to negotiate, draft and pass
one of the world’s most
respected and celebrated constitutions.
For years, that negotiation process
was marred by sabotage, assassinations,
boycotts and bloodshed.
And yet, despite these many challenges,
it also delivered a functioning
electoral process
and a visionary blueprint
for a transformed society in South Africa.
This blueprint contained
not just a bill of rights,
but a bill of public goods,
a promissory note and a commitment
to deliver a demonstrably better life
for all of South Africa's people.
In the decades since, however,
that promise has not adequately been kept,
largely because of the failure
of our political leaders
to live up to the promise
of the country's hard-won transition.
These failures have led many young people
today to express their preference
for an authoritarian path,
believing that gaining access
to their most basic needs
is worth sacrificing the right to vote
and to participate
in democratic governance.
But history and research have shown us
that democracy is still worth fighting for
despite the inadequacies of its leaders.
And so, to get South Africa to a place
where democracy can thrive,
we need a revolution
in political leadership.
This has become my life's work.
South Africa's constitution
is widely considered
to be one of the most unique
constitutions around the world.
This is primarily because
we have a bill of rights,
which both declares our freedoms
and guarantees our right to access things
such as health care, water,
education, housing,
a protected and sustainable environment,
and nutrition and shelter for children.
Not many states have codified the right
to access specific government services
into their supreme law.
Some of these rights are absolute,
including the rights to basic education,
while others, such as the right
to housing, water, food,
health care and social security,
are considered progressively
realizable rights.
This means that the constitution
places an obligation on all governments,
regardless of political affiliation
and regardless of the promises
contained in their political manifestos,
to implement measures that will lead
to the full realization of these rights.
This is why I say our bill of rights
is also a bill of public goods.
But the South Africa
that young people live in today
is also one of the most
unequal societies on Earth.
The South Africa of young people today
is one of prolonged energy
and water shortages
that render life
undignified and intolerable.
It is a country mired
in institutionalized corruption
at the very highest levels.
It is a country whose education
outcomes are so poor
that our fourth-grade learners
have the worst reading ability
in the world:
81 percent are incapable
of reading for meaning.
Our constitution may guarantee our rights,
but poor leadership has hindered
our ability to access those rights.
And as a result, the country’s
most vulnerable citizens
have lost faith in the promise
of South African democracy.
So much so that in a 2021 study
by the Pan-African,
non-partisan research
network Afrobarometer,
two-thirds of South Africans said
that they would be willing
to give up elections
if a non-elected government
could provide them
with guaranteed security,
housing and jobs.
46 percent of the survey respondents
said that they would be
very willing to do so.
That’s nearly half.
And the highest levels
of support for this proposal
were amongst younger
and more educated respondents.
The disillusionment
with democracy in South Africa
is also borne out by statistics
from our electoral commission,
which point to a sustained decline
in voter participation numbers,
particularly amongst young
people in South Africa.
Part of that may be
because anybody under the age of 35
in South Africa has only ever experienced
life in a democratic society.
And to them, that society
is simply not that visionary nation
of ethical leaders
delivering a society
based on social justice
and fundamental human rights.
And so they feel no motivation
to fight for a democracy
that doesn't actually
deliver on its promises.
I desperately want that to change
before South Africa slips
into an authoritarian trap.
I first ran for elected
political office in 2008,
at the age of 28,
hoping to right these very wrongs.
I wanted to contribute to the high-minded
and constitutionally enshrined
idea of South Africa.
A country of triumph over diversity,
a place which had put the injustices
of the past so far behind it,
that education, health care,
water and safety
were considered basic human rights.
In 2009, I was elected
into a national assembly
and to which I was one
of the youngest members of parliament.
But by then the contagion of corruption
had already begun to infiltrate
the political class,
and its consequences --
the declining quality of service delivery,
the rapid decay of public infrastructure,
the communities neglected
and the tensions inflamed --
were increasingly visible in daily life.
I resigned from active politics
at the beginning of my second term,
burned out, frustrated and disillusioned
by how easily hubris,
corruption and incompetence could stifle
the country's socioeconomic progress.
But even at my most jaded,
I understood that the challenge lay
with the quality of leaders
in political office,
not with the system in which
they were duty bound to serve.
And so today,
my work is focused on building
capacity in the right leaders,
people of integrity, community mindedness,
skill, self awareness,
and to help them to make the transition
into political and government
leadership roles in South Africa
and also throughout the African continent.
I started an organization
called Futurelect to do just this,
with a special emphasis on programs
that support women
to run for elected political office
and occupy senior,
influential and impactful roles
in our democracies.
We do this not only
because it's fair and just
for women to have equal
representation in political life,
but also because countless studies
about diversity and leadership have shown
that when more women are around
the decision-making table,
progress towards objectives
improves dramatically.
The very same is true
of political leadership.
So at Futurelect, we bring together
classes of young people
and women leaders who come from a range
of political and ideological traditions,
some having no political
affiliation at all,
to help shape the quality of leadership
on the continent for the future.
My experience in politics strengthened
my belief that values,
character and purpose in our leaders
matter far more than the ideology
and political persuasion.
So the values that we amplify
at Futurelect,
the ones we expect our fellows to embody,
include a commitment
to democratic governance,
a belief in the equality
and legitimacy of all people,
the pursuit of policy
based on evidence, not prejudice,
and a keen awareness that political
leadership is, first and foremost,
about people, not prestige or position.
We're building a community of ethical
leaders from around the country,
the region and the continent.
Young people and women
who can hold each other accountable
based on shared values,
and who can model
a different kind of leadership
in a world which is drunk
with polarization
and hopelessly entrenched political views.
The time that our fellows spend
developing their leadership abilities
also enables them
to stress-test their positions
amongst people who share their values
but may not share their politics.
And also to articulate a vision
for their leadership in government
and the public sector.
Our graduates have run
for office in elections,
some successfully and some not.
Those who have been unsuccessful
are retooling their strategies
and preparing to contest again.
Their resilience inspires me.
Our graduates are also political
appointees in local, state-level
and national-level administrations.
They work with cabinet ministers, mayors,
governors and one
in their country's presidency.
At the same time,
I'm also committed to fortifying
young South Africans' belief
in democracy's power and potential.
So we are also investing
in active citizenship
by creating freely available
online learning tools
to support new generations
of young citizens
and young voters to show up
in between elections,
demand accountability
from their public representatives,
participate robustly
in the governance of their country,
and ultimately to see themselves as part
of the fabric of our democratic system.
Autocratic political entrepreneurs
are very fond of claiming
that you cannot eat a constitution
or that democracy does not put
food on the table.
This has been proven time
and time again to be untrue.
But our ability to demonstrate that
is tragically diminished
when we elect leaders
who lack the commitment,
the integrity and the ability
to deliver on the massive potential
of democratic government.
When we recognize that no political leader
or party in any democracy
has a monopoly on good governance,
we can hold all leaders accountable
for the values-based fundamentals
that ensure all governments
truly represent
the interests of the people
who elected them.
And when leaders of integrity and purpose
come together across political lines,
even in the most heightened
and dangerous of circumstances,
we know that they are capable
of crafting laws and building systems
that reflect and reinforce
our very highest aspirations.
Constitutions can feed us.
Democracies can provide us
with shelter and safety,
but only if we take active
responsibility for them
and elect leaders who can deliver
on democracy's extraordinary potential.
Thank you.
(Applause)